hallo mein name ist luca und meine
lieben freunde morgen ist der erste 12
2009 senders am morgen um 15 uhr
launischen neue klammerten
also macht euch auf jeden fall ein
dickes rotes kreuz morgen 15 uhr für den
kalender ein dass er da in den luca
minister von ge geht allerdings sehe
dies schon bei eingeblendet wir machen
heute kinderserien intro verraten aber
ich kann das nicht weil meine mutter hat
mich nur von spongebob gesetzt das merkt
man an deiner intelligenz
[Musik]
[Applaus]
keine ahnung ich weiß es sich keine
angehörigen könnten kenntnisse erkennen
dabei ich auch nicht auch nie drauf
gekommen
das hatte ich aber herzlich letztes mal
schon mit junge nils holgersson mich
nein was geht es darum den jungen der
aus seiner ganz rum
[Musik]
ok sind einfach an die augen für die tf
das detaillierte da ist sogar richtig
disney aber okay er steht gerade eins zu
eins
[Musik]
also sowas pipi lampe gesagt man ist
erst mal meine spiele lang strom
sie schreien die schlüpfenden
langstrumpf die auch nicht arbeitet sagt
am schlümpfe wusste ich halt richtig
stark verwahrlost ist dass die schlümpfe
von haribo schmecken aber heftigkeit was
man dazu sagen
[Musik]
waffen ganz dicken schneller
ja ich nur so ich musste den wagen auch
noch mal bock dass sie dazu gucken
sie haben auch ein 2 3 folgen
doch ich darf schon doch tommy james
alltags okay sie 32 das macht mega spaß
[Musik]
keine ahnung
[Applaus]
deggendorf
jan o
habe ich nie geküsst ich komme im leben
nicht genau was das elend rolls das
kennst ja ich kann diesen job osten auf
dem flop von david braig deckel source
und riegel coupé sehr ich weiss nicht
wie dies jetzt im leben nicht gedacht
dass ich so krank bin ich hätte alles
gedacht er ist 3 zu 3
[Musik]
das ist ja das kann jeder das ist gar
nicht weiter anderen selbst von sportal
alles klar du musst jetzt punkten
[Musik]
bist du meinst du das hier also du musst
ja will zu den punkt oder durch es gibt
eine serie die hakuna matata ich kenne
rack oder mathe hatte nur von könig der
löwen
da willst du blöd
oh mein gott du kannst
[Musik]
gummi wenn ich 100 prozentig warte ich
wohl vor bis zum wings direktausgleich
ok 15 59
doch noch nicht 65
das ist ja ein kopf an kopf rennen hier
[Musik]
die partie parat den grund ich hatte nur
gesagt wegen der pfeife zu beginnen
ich habe gesagt okay wenn der ganze
wahnsinn
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sabrina und ein grund der helfende hände
doch kommen können oh mein gott sousa la
boum sabrina safe da hätte man auf mein
gott ok krasses war blöd das ist
in solche videos ist es immer ganz
schwierig weil viele wahrscheinlich dazu
ich denke seid ihr nun seine crew was
einfach gesagt ich weiß nicht ich wollte
mein hund balu nennen weil ich die serie
für immer geguckt
[Musik]
ja auch ein paar sekunden später ich
habe auch gesagt dass die leute wegen
der musik
aber es sind immer noch sieben zu 600
diesen spruch mag ich gern wie du
zehnmal hakuna matata sagen sie nicht da
jetzt die pokalpartie timo putz ganz
richtig auseinandergenommen
ich krieg doch keinen punkt dagobert
duck tick trick und track oder dann doch
ist es dass er irgendwie so sagt hayes
wieder komplett daneben haben wir gar
keine ahnung und gesagt big trick und
track das doch diese drei kleinen zu
drillingen irgendwie kann ja voll rein
ratsländer
[Musik]
ja okay okay
übrigens auch mal mehr schwächen avio
rufus genannt sagt wofür es ist kein
märchen sondern ein nacktmull
[Musik]
ich weiß es weiter
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
ich sag dir noch einmal und dann kommt
das sich hören er wollte
[Musik]
die box
die sicherlich aber irgendwoher
kennst du ich kenne sie nicht
[Musik]
kein kunde hätte bettwäsche von ihr so
richtig fett ihr körper und meine band
weiß du brauchst du noch einen punkt
[Musik]
tags version aufkeimten
digimon mein gott ich komme daran die
gar nicht kommen der wagen naja du dich
besser
mama ich muss wirklich sagen es ist
wirklich aber teils nein ich hab dich
schon geist hat dann floss auch
aufgezogen ich bin klein habe ich die
option stimmt ja also eigentlich hab ich
noch nie gegen dich gewonnen
kinder lieben freunde an der stelle
benannt ist das heutige wir jetzt auch
beenden denn solch gefallen hat wie wir
hier kinderserien tv intro verraten
haben dass auf jeden fall gerne einen
daumen runter die deponierten einen
kanal shop besonders vorbildlichen
sandra ich als laserdruck auf instagram
und lang so ein tag nur aber genau
morgen 15 uhr kommt ihr dick und doof
merching shop in lucka minister punkt.de
und auch neue sachen mit dem smiley
drauf also schaut dort auch gern morgen
15 uhr vorbei war sonst kommt jetzt erst
mal das auto
[Musik]